it's great to be joined today on the
program by Maj Richard ogia who's a
highly decorated 24-year Army veteran
West Virginia State Senator also a
Democratic candidate for the nomination
for the Democratic nomination candidate
for the Democratic nomination for
president in 2020 Richard so great to
talk to you I appreciate you joining me
today hey thank you and I appreciate you
having me on so let's start I mean for
people who aren't familiar with you you
are maybe in the grand scheme of things
although less so in West Virginia not
the sort of prototypical model of a
candidate for president on the
Democratic side talk a little bit about
your background sort of the politics you
grew up around your military background
and kind of how that influenced what
your politics are today well you know I
actually never thought that I would be
in politics it was not something that I
was really interested in you know I grew
up in an area here in West Virginia the
southern part of West Virginia and when
I graduated high school there were very
few options it was basically dig coal
sell drugs or join the military and I
chose the path of the military I enjoyed
my time in the military I did you know
24 years but when I finally decided to
retire and return back home I was
absolutely shocked and saddened at bat
what I saw you know I come back here and
I found people that were supposed to be
leaders you know they had their hands in
the cookie jar in the military you know
you live in a bubble and everyone to my
left and my right was a light airborne
sapper everybody that my wife you know
dealt with was a military spouse
everyone that my children played with
were military brats you know we lived on
base or we lived right off base you know
different occasions but everyone that
was around us was part of the military
community and you you tend to think that
you know that's how life is across this
country you deploy to places like Iraq
and Afghanistan and you do they
because you believe that your your gonna
you gonna fight to give those people
over there a sliver the greatness that
we have in America you lose people that
you love you know your your your closest
friends you know we we call them battle
buddies you know we consider them to be
brothers and sisters and you cope with
that by saying that you know they died
for a good cause
and then you get out of the military and
you come home and you realize that the
leaders that you see on the civilian
side are nothing like the leaders that
you had in the military you know in the
military you don't eat until your troops
are fed in the military you lead from
the front
you can't lead from behind you know
behind a desk and and that's exactly
what I saw I retired from the military
and I come home and I found that you
know we had people with their hands in
the cookie jar and nothing was going on
around here you know I saw an opioid
epidemic that was killing thousands upon
thousands of people that has destroyed
the communities we had elderly people
that were cutting their meds in half we
had children that were you know going to
bed hungry I retired and I started
teaching JROTC at a local high school
Chattanooga regional high school and on
the first day I saw a young lady that
had a shirt on that had holes in it and
it was dirty and during the lunch time
the cafeteria ladies walked out and put
these big metal trays of corn bombs on
the table and they said no extra corn
dogs and I saw girls jump over tables to
grab handfuls of the corn dogs to put in
their persons and I realized it's
because they're hungry
and they want to have some food when
they get home so I realized that these
leaders were not doing their jobs
so I started challenging these leaders I
started calling them out and of course
you know when I when I was in the
military every time I come home
everybody wanted to Pat me on the back
and tell me you know we we respect your
service all these leaders when I come
home I I started a nonprofit
organization that was picking up trash
pulling tires out of the creeks covering
graffiti feeding people sending kids to
school with new shoes on their feet and
every politician were to come around
take photograph with us and give the
thumbs up like they're with us they
wasn't with this one who is picking up
the trash and pulling the tires out of
the creeks but they wanted to come take
photographs in front of the stacks of
tires and the mounds of trash and and
and Richard if I may just so we can get
a figure how this plays into your
politics you are not a particularly
liberal guy growing up right and in 2016
you actually voted for Donald Trump and
will I'm sure we'll get to that and
you've since sort of had a political
awakening of sorts how much of a
conservative guy were you growing up you
know I don't think it's necessarily
conservative you know either side I
think I'm pretty much the type of person
that kind of walks right down the middle
and I think there's a lot of people
around here that are that way but you
know what happened in terms of the 2016
election I wanted Bernie Sanders you
know and I think a lot of most people
around here did you know Bernie Sanders
won all 55 counties but you know it
basically it was robbed from Bernie
Sanders in the primary you mean
absolutely was robbed from Bernie
Sanders in the primary and I mean they
they show where you know the Democratic
Party's basically said you know Hillary
Clinton and that was not what the people
wanted so number one the people in West
Virginia oughta bath he felt like their
vote was stolen from them so and it was
stolen from them and given to Hillary
Clinton so number one that right there
caused a lot of anger around here then
you had the two people Donald Trump
Hillary Clinton and you know it turned
out to be the lesser of two evils every
I knew the things that Donald Trump was
saying was a lot of it was garbage in
terms of the way he spoke about women
and things like I didn't appreciate that
but at the end of the day I look out my
window and I look at the community in
which I live in and the majority of
people here rely on coal and I
understand we've got to we've got to
pull away coal is no longer going to be
viable as an energy source we've got to
bring newer opportunities in here to
transition for when coal is gone but
right now that's the only way these
people know how to feed their family
yeah and we'll actually we'll get to
energy a little bit but not to skip
ahead just
everybody really understands your
background so you're saying that in the
in the Democratic primary in 2016 you
voted for Bernie Sanders is that correct
and ultimately he lost and as you say of
course there were circumstances in the
Democratic primary which we've talked
about on the program many times in our
audience will be familiar with you
eventually made the decision that as a
moderate guy you were going to vote for
Trump over Hillary Clinton and you've
believed it was a lesser of two evils
choice is that right that's right
because he was talking about putting
these coal miners back to work and she
was talking about you know job training
with jobs that do not exist in West
Virginia so you know it become who could
put people who get people food on the
table now is there a case to be made
that Donald Trump sort of cow toeing to
the pro coal community which is an
important community in West Virginia
economically no question about it
was in a sense of fantasy because the
free market is sort of deciding that
coal is going away that ultimately you
can maybe artificially create some coal
jobs in the short run but that this is
an industry that is dying wouldn't we be
better served saying let's figure out
how to deal with that rather than
pretending we're going to create coal
jobs that ultimately are going to
disappear and you're right you're
absolutely right with that but you know
it's one of those things where at that
time it was all about looking at the
people and saying you know they need
something and they need something now
you know it's okay but then if you was
to go up to Detroit and say that you're
gonna bring all the jobs back through
for the auto industry those people up
there even though that they may think
well I don't know if it's possible but
they're gonna have a little bit of hope
because it's better than then then what
the other alternative is oh so that's
actually more interest so so in a sense
you do do you think that when Donald
Trump was saying we're gonna just grow
the coal industry we're bringing back
coal jobs are you saying people knew it
wasn't true but it's still appealed to
them anyway no I'm not saying that they
they knew it wasn't true I'm saying that
you know there comes a
when if that's the only thing that you
have if you're a coal miner and you
don't have you know the truth is is you
know you don't have to have a college
degree to be a coal miner but you can
make a lot of money as a coal miner you
can support your family you can provide
for your family and it gets to the point
where you start to think you know if
it's gone then the only thing that I
have left is your windi's and your your
Walmarts or I have to leave and then you
just want it to - when somebody says
they can keep it you are willing to put
your trust in that person because you
know that's all you have and and that's
and that's a hard it's a hard pill to
swallow
but you know that's what that's what it
was you know and has it has he turned
cold around well you know Co has we have
had an uptick in coal but it wasn't very
long ago just a couple of weeks before
the midterm elections we had a major
coal mine right in Wileman County shut
down and you're talking over 400 jobs I
can assure you those those 400 plus
families are wondering I thought this
was supposed to be great I thought we
were supposed to be able to keep this
storm forever but they're starting to
realize it's not the case so what
ultimately changed your mind on Trump
were you not only opposed Trump now but
are running as a Democrat what was it
that pushed you away after deciding to
vote for him in 2016 you know it was
everything I mean once he once he took
over it's been a complete circus I mean
you know I've said from day one you know
kick your kids out of the oval office
put your cell phone down stop stop
tweeting to tweet fighting with everyone
you know listen to the people that you
surround yourself with successful
leaders surround themselves with
intelligent people and the people that
he surrounded himself with even in the
beginning have been absolute train wreck
you know Betsy DeVos education No
you know I mean it's it's and then the
people that he has the people that are
amazing that he has surrounded himself
with himself with he doesn't listen to I
mean you know he put you know generals
Kelly and mattis and you know both of
them are now
gone and they're gone because he refuses
to listen to brilliant military minds he
thinks that he knows more than the
generals and that is absolutely the
wrong you know stance to take you know
he has not surrounds himself with and
tells you people and it has been a
complete train wreck ever since so as
far as your candidacy now for for 2020
are you how do you balance or what is
the sort of balance between opposing the
Trump agenda but also creating and
putting forward ideas of your own a sort
of more aspirational approach how do you
balance the two where is the balance
well you know when it comes to me I'm
pushing pillars that I want to to to you
know release to everyone and I believe
that there these are things that that
people will agree with and a lot of
people will like seeing coming from
somebody who's running for the
presidency of the United States of
America you know I'm talking about
sacrifice
you know once again remember I'm a
military guy today a staff sergeant in
the military that is in harm's way that
has two children qualifies for food
stamps now you don't join the military
for pay everybody knows who you don't
join the military to become rich but
that's a life of sacrifice and that's
exactly what our servicemen and women do
every day they sacrifice but we've got
people that run for office your
congressmen your Senators President
United States and they stand in front of
you and they say I'm gonna fight for you
I'm gonna work for you I'm gonna do
everything in my life to improve your
lives that's not what they're doing
they're not sacrificing okay they become
a congressman they become a senator and
you know within one or two terms there
were thirty million dollars they know
what this is about wealth and power to
the majority of people that throw their
hat in the ring and you know what they
get in office and it's not about trying
to solve problems it's about figuring
out who they
they can impress to be able to secure
that next level job for when they are
done being in politics you know we know
that lobbyists you know Gries the
pockets and we know that a lot of these
people do everything in their power to
impress those lobbyists because they
know that those lobbyists are the ones
that are going to put the good word in
for them so that they can get that job
being a lobbyist when they're done with
politics and we know that 35% of
congressmen become lobbyists 50% of
senators become lobbyists and that's why
you know they're not sacrificing it's
self-serving is what it is it's not
selfless service and that's where we're
at so you know the things that I'm
saying you know these are things that
I'm willing to follow with follow
through with you know in terms of how
I'm going to deal with issues I will
surround myself with intelligent folks
and I will listen to what they have to
say and we will make sure that I get
everything that I need when I make my
decision so that I know that when I do
make my decision I will be helping
people and not hurting people and to me
that's the way that you have to be and
that deals with everything here in
America deals with stuff you know
outside this country and you know that's
exactly the way where I stand all right
let's say that's a good place to pause
our conversation and we'll dig into the
specific issues with Richard oh Jetta on
tomorrow's program he is running for
president in 2020 Richard Oh Jetta is a
West Virginia state senator and we will
continue our conversation with him on
tomorrow's program we're continuing our
conversation today with major Richard O
jeddah who's a highly decorated 24-year
Army veteran West Virginia State Senator
he is running for president in 2020 on
the Democratic side let's talk a little
bit more specifically about the 20/20
campaign electability other candidates
talk a little bit about the strategy for
states like my state Massachusetts for
example where in early polls folks like
Joe Biden and Bernie Sanders and
Elizabeth Warren are sort of at the top
of that that early presidential polling
what is the case to be made as to why a
progressive Massachusetts voter should
support Richard o jeddah who admittedly
has a number of progressive progressive
policies today but as you said did vote
for Donald Trump in 2016 is more of a
moderate down the middle guy as you
mentioned yesterday what's the case for
that voter to support you over some of
the great options that that already are
on the table as possible candidates well
I think you know thing is once the
people get an opportunity to meet me to
hear the things that I'm saying I think
that they will agree with me
you know right now everybody knows that
you're gonna have a few people that are
gonna throw their hat in the ring mm-hmm
and these are lifetime politicians they
have no concept of what life is like to
the working class citizen out there you
know as a matter of fact I'm going to go
ahead and say it a lot of them are not
real Democrats because I believe what a
real Democrat is is a person who puts
working-class citizens first yeah what
that seems I mean I'm not your political
adviser by any means but that seems like
risky territory to talk about who's a
real Democrat because people could say
well hold on a second Richard or jeddah
voted for Trump in 2016 is he really a
real Democrat absolutely because I care
about the working-class citizens
you know I voted for Trump which I
regret to this day but I voted for Trump
because I was putting the working-class
citizens first you know it wasn't about
me it was about the people in which I
where I live and wanting to make sure
that they can continue putting food on
the table it's about supporting unions
you're not going to find anybody that's
more fiercely supportive of unions than
I am
that's a fact I don't care who those are
hat in the ring and I guarantee you
labor unions will be able to tell you
that it's it's taking care of our
elderly you know and I mean by real by
making sure stop allowing these people
put their hands in the cookie jar Social
Security I'm willing to raise the cap on
Social Security okay is that what would
you raise it - that's an interesting
we've been talking about that for a
while what would you get rid of the cap
altogether or raise it to a particular
number
it wouldn't bother me to get rid of the
cap altogether you know buddy pays that
their fair share but I mean once again
you know get rid of if we got rid of the
cap Social Security will be here not
only for our children but if we got rid
of the cap so we imagine what could be
done with Social Security what would you
do in terms of Taxation would you what
do you think about the tax brackets that
are currently in place how would you
change that would you make the system
more progressive less progressive well
you know in terms of taxes I don't have
a problem I don't have a problem raising
taxes if it's going to go for a good
cause
okay in terms of these you know tax
breaks and tax cuts that are always for
the top one percent you know I'm not in
favor of all that you know I think that
you know the average citizen out here
the ones are the strengthen this big tax
break that was just given to the top one
percent out there you know that's gonna
be great for them but for the average
citizen our stuffs gonna sunset here
pretty soon we'll have nothing you know
I think that we need to be equal to
cross the board let everybody be able to
keep their their capabilities for for
you know the long term but you know I
mean like I said you know I don't have a
problem raising taxes if it's going to
go for a good cause how high do you
think that the highest bracket should be
well how much money can a person make I
mean you know I to me I mean everybody
pay their equal share of taxes right but
what I'm saying is would you like to see
a 50 percent top marginal tax rate
seventy-five percent at what income
would that kick in should there be a
special rate for people earning over ten
million dollars a year a hundred million
dollars a year well you mean a special
rate you mean a special when you say
special minute I mean that you would
create a bracket marginal tax rate where
even if the sort of you know 39.5% kicks
in at four hundred thousand that you
would say okay if your income is over 20
million a year every dollar over 20
million you will pay seventy percent or
75 percent is that something you would
be in favor of or there's that same - hi
- you you know I have to look at those
things right there you know like I said
I'm that's one of the things I really
need
focus and do some more research on
Ferrand I don't want I don't want to go
ahead and give you an answer on
something yeah and later on down the
road you know figure out another plan or
something like that but once again I
think that everybody needs to pay their
fair share you know we keep giving tax
breaks to the top 1% in this country and
the bottom are the ones that are
carrying everything on their backs so
you know I want to make sure that it's
more even across-the-board
geopolitically shifting gears a little
bit when you see what's happening in
Syria Donald Trump deciding to pull
troops from Syria just after we were
told troops would be staying in Syria
for some time
you've got General Wesley Clark now
saying he's hearing from allies that
they're wondering whether maybe Trump
was blackmailed or given a payoff to do
this because it seems to go completely
counter to both logic and what we saw
said by the Secretary of Defense before
his resignation and subsequent you can't
quit because I'm firing you incident
what do you see as the right path in
Syria well number one it's it's
listening to you know the military minds
and obviously you know Donald Trump does
not do that and I believe it's probably
one of the reasons why you know general
mattis's is is going ahead and stepping
away you know I think nothing surprises
me when it comes to Donald Trump about
his decisions that he makes obviously he
thinks that he knows more about you know
what's going on in Syria then the people
that you know are on the ground over
there I think it's a it's a big mistake
look you know it's it's okay for us to
be in places to be able to help protect
our allies the Kurdish people who have
always been with us you know and we
believe that if we pull away from there
it will it will not be long and
somebody's going to come in there
they're probably going to absolutely
annihilate the Kurdish people but once
again these are people who stood with us
for a long time all the way back to
Desert Shield Desert Storm
but you know I I want to go ahead and
said also that I'm not for spending you
know decades in countries doing things
like you know building roads and things
like that when we don't really have a
major reason to actually be spending
that kind of money and putting those
kind of boots on the ground in places
like
but then in places like what we have in
Syria I think that it's it is absolutely
a bad move to pull our troops out of
there especially when the people on the
ground are saying no please don't
did you support initially going into
Syria because I think that there's two
different questions there I think that a
principled progressive can say I was not
in favor of going in in the first place
but now that we're there there needs to
be a strategic reason to leave and to
leave now and we want to make sure that
we know what the reasons are that we're
leaving what was your initial position
on going into Syria well look I don't
have an issue going in if we're talking
about going in and and and and getting
people like Isis you know I have no
issues at all because these are people
that you know if you don't crush them
they will rebuild and they will come at
you I have no problems going into a
place you know like like Syria to be
able to to wipe out you know
organizations like Isis al Qaeda and
things like that but you know I you know
like I said once you're there you know
let's listen to the to the the people
that have boots on the ground you know
let's not pull people out unless we know
it's the right thing to do you know I
hate to say it you know we pulled out of
Iraq what happened when we pulled out of
Iraq you know they took right back over
Ali took back the cities that's
interesting so when it came to Iraq what
was your position on the initial
invasion in 2003 well I was in the
military I was a company commander at
that time you know to me I was the I was
you know deployed in the service of this
nation I was proud to go it was when I
got to Iraq and I started looking around
and I realized that you know money is
what controls everything you know you
you see you know things that are going
on over there you know at the time in
2004-2005 I believe there was a 163 plus
thousand you know troops on the ground
and you know we were paying $200 per
troop per day for food I don't know if
anybody who was eating that kind of food
over their period but yet we were paying
that kind of money you know it doesn't
take long to realize that we're here we
may be here to fight an enemy but we're
all
so here because somebody is putting a
lot of money in the pockets of
contractors and that's exactly what it
was and I believe that's why we're still
in Afghanistan building roads in places
we're not even - the people don't even
own the car yeah the issue I'm sort of
glad you brought up Iraq because it gets
us to sort of another issue that's both
the geopolitics issue but also an
environment issue and a domestic issue
which is that that of oil and fossil
fuels and climate change and I'm curious
you know in part one of the interview
you talked yesterday about how the pro
coal rhetoric from trump was appealing
to you initially although of course you
now realize that that it was a total
farce how do you see approaching the
issue of fossil fuels in the United
States given that you are a state
senator in West Virginia a state that's
heavily dependent on fossil fuel revenue
considering the way in which our
relationship with Saudi Arabia is
influenced by the fact that they have us
figuratively and and literally over a
barrel when when it comes to oil what
would be your approach to fossil fuels
do you want to get us off of fossil
fuels and if so how absolutely I support
the green New Deal wholeheartedly I just
wish it was now let's bring those drink
let's bring those green jobs to places
like West Virginia so our coal miners
can transition over and start getting
those jobs you know we know that there's
we're almost at the point where we're at
the point of no return where if we go
past this date 2035 let's say it's 2035
there's no turning back we might as well
just sit and watch the earth die around
us we have the ability right now to turn
to turn directions and we've got to do
it you know look I understand you know
metallurgical coal is cold the create
steel we need steel production because
we have infrastructure issues we've got
a military might that's been born for 18
straight years but let me tell you
something coal as an energy source is
gone and we need to transition I just
don't want us to pull the plug on it
before we look at these people out here
and provide them with opportunities to
feed their family and they need more
than Wendy's and McDonald's to do so
let's bring those green energy jobs to
West Virginia now
and solar you name it we want it we can
build solar panels bring it to West
Virginia let's allow my people to
transition and let's go ahead and get
away from all fossil fuels part of why
that doesn't happen as quickly as maybe
it otherwise would is because of
subsidies on fossil fuels would you pull
those subsidies yes I would and what
about the argument that many employers
in your state of West Virginia will make
that that is going to kill thousands of
jobs I will tell them that's why it's
important for all of us to get together
and say let's get these green jobs down
here now you know once again we have a
we have a land and if we cross that line
we might as well sit and watch the earth
die around us we cannot allow us to get
to that line so let's go ahead and try
and change directions well I agree with
you I agree with you I worry that that
may not be a that that not maybe may not
be welcomed as warmly in West Virginia
as it would in Boston Massachusetts but
how could I possibly disagree but just
because I'm from West Virginia
doesn't mean I'm gonna go down with the
ship you know I support my you know I
love my state and I love the people
within my state but you know I also you
know want to see us all survive and I
think that we can let's bring those
capabilities to West Virginia so we if
we transition those coal miners to
decent jobs that pay well that they
could provide the family with they will
be very pleased with that you're not
gonna find a coal miner that says I
can't wait when my son turns 18 years
old so we can follow me down that mine
the coal miners want more for their
children they want that and we need to
be able to provide them with that
certainly can't argue with that
we've been speaking with major Richard o
jeddah who's a highly decorated 24-year
Army veteran West Virginia state senator
and he's running for president in 2020 a
Richard really a pleasure having you on
I appreciate it well thank you very much
for having me on